[Musique]
monaco
c'est bien tout
super génial part d'être côtés de tennis
tour t'asseoir je sais il ya deux ans de
ça oui j'avais même pas reconnus à nyon
alors je vais parler de la pluie et du
beau temps parce que je suis incapable
de parler américains pour parler trop
vite et puis avec un accent si spécial
c'est le monde entier parti il a reconnu
ses bêtes pour le meilleur feeling et je
suis ferry
salut à fournir à prendre et je reste en
contact puis à coup ils m'ont demandé
pour pour aller tourner en amazonie avec
eux je suis parti super merci trois mois
dans une tribu sauvage c'est julien
[Musique]
de vingt ans après être descendue pour
la première fois sur cannes une
croisette qui les a rendus célèbres dans
le monde entier a fait toutes les
grandes villes du monde light à tokyo à
pékin moscou larry à rio tout le monde
entier des akan
[Musique]